coming up next week in Brussels TTIP
migrants welcome to the agenda it's been
said that no idea is so landis then it
should not be considered but as conflict
rages on over how trade disputes should
be resolved is there any salvation for
the transatlantic trade deal in April 6
out of 14 that parliamentary committees
voted to reject the private arbitration
mechanism under TTIP the hard sell
continues for EU trade commission
Cecilia malmström will present the
Commission's latest ideas for and Dennis
Dale mate on Wednesday in the aftermath
of Alexis Lake scandal Belgium Ireland
and Netherlands and of course Luxembourg
have all been under the microscope for
having dodgy taxes so what could be in
the cards were fighting the highest tier
of tax dodgers members of parliament
special committee on tax reliefs will
debate with Competition Commission and
Margaret message' who is currently
tasked with investigating the big tax
dodge find out or on Tuesday
triple-decker felt migrants were one of
the deadliest disasters at sea could it
also be proposed to tackle one of the
root causes behind migration Olivia has
been a country ever since the overthrow
of Colonel Gaddafi in 2011 smugglers
have seized opportunity to ferry
thousands of migrants across the
Mediterranean as warring militias
grapple for power and Isis to make their
advance into the country with extremism
on its doorstep is it time for Europe to
act on Tuesday look out for security
strategy here and on Libya and on
Wednesday the civil liberties committee
will also vote to clarify rules related
to the asylum unaccompanied minors a
week on from a devastating earthquake in
Nepal the slow pace of aid has left
survivors frustrated 5,000 lives were
lost when the 7.8 magnitude earthquake
struck last Saturday that sugar could
well double as hopes fade for survivors
the millions left London capital or the
moat cuttlefishes
are in urgent need of food water and
shelter the European Commission has
released three million euros in
emergency aid
what will Parliament pledged the
Development Committee will debate on
Wednesday
and don't forget the Parliament will
open its doors to the public on Saturday
9th of May if you want to know how the
institution works
get yourself down there and that's all
we have for this agenda take care and
enjoy the week